in this video we'll talk about lymph
node this is a high yield video for
USMLE step one
lymph node is a highly specialized
secondary lymphoid organ secondary
lymphoid organs at those organs where
immune cells are not born but they
reside there they gets activated for
their job
lymph node are fully committed in
regulation of the immune responses lymph
node are encapsulated a bean shaped
structure which are populated by
dendritic cell T cell and the B cells
lymph node is distributed all over the
body adult humans will have
approximately 800 to thousand lymph node
generally cited in neck axillary thorax
abdomen or in the groin region
now let us talk about the
subdivisions of the lymph node so here
we can see the efferent lymphatics and
here we can see the afferent lymphatics
okay let me simplify this is the entry
and the exit point but before that you
can see there are blood vessels also
coming in
the afferent lymphatics are the entry
point for several immune cells into the
lymph node the efferential lymphatic is
the exit point for several cells out
from the lymph node
now blood vessels can carry several
cells like T cells and B cells into the
lymph node
dendritic cells which can recognize
antigen and pathogens in the periphery
can enter the lymph node through the
afferent lymphatics
and from the efferent lymphatics
activated B cell T cell or the
renderetic cell can circulate out
so here is an important structure the
outer cortex just beneath the outer
cortex there would be the paracortics
and inside there is medulla
so paracortics and the follicle are two
important structures
in context of lymph node the follicles
are pretty much follicular roundish
structure in the lymph node follicle and
paracortex harbor different type of
cells paracortics however the T Cell so
paracortics is simply the T Cell Zone
and follicle is the B cell Zone
so B cells and T cells get activated and
several process of differentiation of
these cells happen in these regions so
in that context
the lymph nodes are super important in
terms of immune modulation
now here let me simplify it even more so
imagine the lymph node is a temporary
army base camp
so the Army uh reside there in different
barracks right so here let's say the
Rangers residing in this Barack and the
SEAL Teams are residing in a different
Barak so exactly in the lymph node there
are dedicated regions for T cells and
the B cells so obviously the paracortex
is the T Cell Barracks let's say and
follicle is the B cell zone now imagine
a situation where a police officer is
approaching these temporary army base
camp to give the news of a possible
Invasion by a terrorist or let's say
so this police officer is very
equivalent to the dendritic cell the
dendritic cell enters the lymph node or
the army base camp through the efferent
lymphatics and interact with the T cells
to activate them so once the dendritic
cell is in it would interact with many
cell types but before that let us try to
understand the histology of the lymph
node so if we look at the histology this
is the capsule this is the medulla just
to orient you and now the most important
structure that should catch your eye is
the follicular region and the
paracordical regions so now train your
eye to understand more follicles and
paracortex regions
now inside the lymph node what happens
is there is there is T Cell Activation
with the MHC two derived peptide
presented to them via the dendritic cell
so when dendritic cell present these
peptides T Cell recognize them via T
cell receptors and with a series of
signaling Cascade T cells get activated
eventually T Cell Activation lead to
proliferation of these T cells and they
would grow in number in a different
slide I have a detailed presentation
about the T Cell Activation you can
quickly access that through I button or
description
now let's talk about the follicles in
the follicle follicular region
T helper cells would interact with the B
cells and that would lead to activation
of these B cells
and once activated B cells would also
proliferate
and proliferating B cells would
eventually undergo important processes
so the activated B cell would undergo
Affinity maturation for their receptors
and class switching that means they
would produce a specific type of
antibody based on the infection type
and Affinity maturation ensures only the
high Affinity interactions are selected
and ultimately they would differentiate
into plasma cell which secretes the
antibody and that leads to the effector
phase of the immune response
so I hope it was useful and we
appreciate what are the different zones
in the lymph node if you need more notes
and flashcards you can visit our
Facebook page or you can follow us on
Instagram to get more notes you can
support our Channel using super thanks
you can contribute by using PayPal paytm
or UPI
and
see you in next video